hello guys I'm Greg Alva and I'm John
you might have caught me in a pilot
presentation called the ghost hunter
Diaries possible because this is a ghost
story trailer we're about to do a
reaction to I thought I'd take a moment
out to promote ghost hunter diaries I
have a supporting role in there go watch
it there's a link in the description box
this was requested oh boy
by a good amount of people but the first
one to request it was a man or woman
named Kay gah gah gah hah J gah react to
a ghost story trailer you got it Jake ah
ha ha ha good fit that's a great panel
of this bit we're gonna watch it now
it's playing don't worry I'll pop it
played at Sundance nice to move all the
time I might even though not faulty
pretty small item listen I just like
thanks for wanting to remember that if
everyone's go back the big winner rating
a 24 194 oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
why do you like rocket has so much
history
[Music]
a writer writes a novel a songwriter
writes a song we do what we can to
endure
whoa
they build our legacy exceeds by peace
and maybe the whole world will remember
you and maybe just a couple of people
but you do what you can to make sure
you're still around after you're gone
[Music]
that was the last thing I was expecting
that trailer to bake Manchester by the
ghost story and so that's good that's a
good mash up there that's pretty great
it goes to the dragon that you gone
ghost sorry gone you don't have it not
like my ghost Shin 11 what was really
about I mean I like the quote they gave
a meditative poem yeah yeah like me if
they're going to look like some kind of
tone poem about you know life and the
things that we leave behind the evidence
of ourselves I don't know if this is
like a literal pilgrimage back to that
house to find the notes used to slip in
the wall or something like that I don't
understand what's going on in this
trailer I don't I'm like really lost
I feel like this trailers made me feel
dumb like I don't know when you think of
what's going on right yeah I don't I
don't quite get a sick sense of plot but
it really is striking at least had the
trailer to me this is very good Scott
Whitehouse very distinct mood and aura
like it definitely seems like it's
getting the feeling across that it wants
to and I don't know for me I like seeing
strings about to sim injury together
because you know that that works on me
it is real vague what movies can you say
that or like that so you've actually
watched the entire thing like be on the
blackberry knew it was like that but I
mean that movie looked like [ __ ] cool
or like under the skin you know under
the skin has like other [ __ ] we got
automatic very you know but this this
caters to something that like this image
of the ghost chic ghost is an image that
I love so like this is going to work on
this is the idea of this trail like this
is cool because I just like watching it
as a like music video yeah I get the
theme is you know life and and you know
what it lasting and you know leaving
some evidence of yourself but I can't
really get a grasp for different stories
just a sequence of memories or something
like that or if it's you know and what
this ghost mode
is that an actual person if it's I gotta
imagine it's not here yeah I don't know
there's this nothing really here that's
like I appreciate that like the
meditative rather hypnotic style that
the trailer was giving it's like a
soothing experience the same time though
I would I would like to feel like
there's you know movie stuff like a
latch on is the thing I don't criticize
anyone who likes this kind of stuff and
I'm knowing me if i watch the it is
nothing probably to go out of my way to
watch if I like somehow felts you know
with a girl and she wants to watch this
badly and I'm gonna want to get laid
yeah I'll go watch it and I feel like I
might end up actually enjoying something
this is the kind of thing I would
probably end up enjoying but I don't
think I'm going to take time out of my
day to go watch the film and the
singular exploration of legacy love lost
in the enormity of existence a recently
deceased white sheeted ghost returns to
a suburban home to try and reconnect
with his burrow Oh Casey Affleck he goes
okay dude that makes it a lot more
interesting yeah I didn't catch it on to
that oh that's why you and she was like
I was wondering I get here when she's
asking a certain questions making more
sense man yeah I don't know I guess just
throw in like John Bailey's voice and
some text so I understand but some of it
straight up he's the only other person
in the trailer so like the thought did
cross my mind of like you know is that
supposed to be him or who's that
supposed to be you know yeah but is it
actually a go yeah as it really goes I
mean that looks like a [ __ ] cool
movie
it's got directed peach dragon hell yeah
you know I mean I'm curious about and
the short film called boy-crazy bikini
mishap of her and boy-crazy gets a job
and boy-crazy in bed and boy-crazy at
the drugstore well there you go J gah
hah yeah Rudy Maura and I'm sure that
was a thrilling reaction you got the two
of us are and guys this would be only an
hour 27 minutes I think I could handle
that under tie seven oh no that's a
movie starring dave franco okay this
stars kate mara and ben affleck so i'd
feel a little better if it sort of in at
all she's all siblings it might get a
little better if it's urban gays yeah
please keeping that depressed thing
going like that alone you don't look
like you just feel like [ __ ] all the
time
I would totally house in Casey Affleck
feels good about himself I don't think
the media is I need help with that I
blame the media the fake news subscribe
to the real rejects this guy if the
athlete as a description box link of so
many things you're going to want to go
there and at least click on one of them
do it there's four things you can check
out on this guy go to the lease of one
of them I guarantee you it'll be worth
someone's time I love you it was your
time but you know somebody you know who
you know interests like that and go
watch the Ghost Hunters diary
Ghost Hunters diary Ghost Hunters diary
pilot I need to it's the exact same kind
of short film actually freeze all motor
function